I FIND THEIR IGNORANCE TO BE
BEYOND BELIEF ABOUT AMERICAN
HISTORY."
HOUSE MINORITY LEADER KEVIN
McCARTHY.
A LITTLE SCHADENFREUDE HERE.
THE TABLE CAN BE TURNED QUICKLY
WHEN RACE IS A CARD THAT YOU
DROP TO AVOID AN ARGUMENT.
IT'S BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT THEY
TRY.
THIS IS INTERNAL WAR.
THIS ISN'T A FAMILY FEUD.
THIS IS BEYOND WHAT ANYONE
THINKS.
WHEN YOU SEE -- YOU ALSO DIDN'T
POINT OUT WHAT AOC'S CHIEF OF
STAFF SAID YESTERDAY.
>> Laura: WE HAVE IT.
BUT IT APPEARED >> TO QUESTION
THIS LEGISLATIVE
MASTERMIND, REFERRING TO
NANCY PELOSI.
>> Laura: 'S IS JUST A PASSING
RIFF HERE?
>> Sean: NO.
BECAUSE WHAT ARE THEY DOING NOW?
THE SOCIALIST DEMOCRATS ARE
TAKING OVER.
NOT ONLY ARE THEY TAKING OVER
THE PARTY, THEY WILL TAKE OVER
ANY DEMOCRAT IN THE PROCESS AS
WELL.
IT IS AFFECTING WHAT THEY'RE
DOING ON THE FLOOR.
WE'VE GOT THE NATIONAL DEFENSE
AUTHORIZATION BILL UP.
FOR 60 YEARS IT HAS BEEN
BIPARTISAN.
IT PASSED WITH 86 VOTES.
THEY'VE MADE IT PARTISAN.
THEY'VE GONE TO POLITICS BECAUSE
OF THE SOCIALISTS.
>> Laura: AOC CRITICIZES
ANYONE AND EVERYONE ANYTIME SHE
WANTS AND SHE HAS SOCIAL MEDIA.
OKAY, THAT'S FINE.
BUT YOU ARE IN THE     THE BIG D
BUT YOU ARE IN THE     THE BIG G
BUT YOU ARE IN THE     THE BIG P
BUT YOU ARE IN THE     THE BIG N
NOW.
BIG DOGS BITE.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO KILL THE
KING, KILLED THE KING.
I CAN'T GET IT.
ARE YOU STRONG, YOUNG, GIRL
POWER, OR IS IT OKAY, I GET HIT
AND IT'S THE DAMSEL IN DISTRESS
THING?
I AM WOMAN, HEAR ME ROAR.
THEN IT'S, OH, NO, DON'T --
I DON'T LIKE THAT.
BE ONE THING.
IT'S KIND OF COOL IN SOME WAYS
BUT THAT JUST DOESN'T WORK I
DON'T THINK.
>> A YEAR AGO THIS MONTH YOU HAD
NEVER HEARD OF HER UNTIL SHE
BEAT SOMEONE IN THE PRIMARY.
SHE HAS MOVED FAST BUT SHE
ALWAYS WANTS TO TRY TO USE
ADVANTAGE.
SHE WILL FIGHT UNTIL YOU TRY TO
FIGHT BACK AND THAT SHE WANTS TO
PLAY THE RACE CARD.
>> Laura: YOU CAN'T EVER
CRITICIZE A PERSON OF COLOR BUT
WE WE HAVE DEMOCRATS OF COLOR
SAYING NO, NO.
LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT IS
HAPPENING THIS WEEKEND, THE
ADMINISTRATION, AND I TALKED
ABOUT THIS WITH JOHN YOO A
COUPLE MOMENTS AGO, THEY'VE
ANNOUNCED THEY ARE DOING TEN
MAJOR CITY RAIDS AND IT WAS
DELAYED EARLIER AFTER AN OUTRAGE
AND I DON'T REALLY KNOW WHY IT
WAS DELAYED, BUT HERE IS
SENATOR MAZIE HIRONO SAYING
ABOUT WHO IS BEING TARGETED.
WATCH.
>> A LOT OF THESE PEOPLE DO HAVE
DEPORTATION ORDERS BUT WE ALSO
KNOW OF CASES OF PEOPLE WHO HAD
DEPORTATION CASE ORDERS AND ARE
APPEALING THESE ORDERS.
>> Laura: I DON'T KNOW IF THAT
IS LIKE A HAWAIIAN WAY OF SAYING
THAT'S NOT TRUE, BUT THAT IS NOT
EVEN TRUE.
EVEN "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
AGREES.
THAT IS NOT THE WORST THING WE
HEARD TODAY.
>> VERY REMINISCENT OF
NAZI GERMANY.
JUST SAYING.
I KNOW YOU ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO
MAKE THAT CONNECTION BUT I'VE
BEEN AROUND LONG ENOUGH AND
BRIGHT ENOUGH TO KNOW THAT THIS
IS VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT HAPPENED
TO THE JEWS.
>> Laura: HOW WILL WE EVER
HAVE A SENSIBLE IMMIGRATION
POLICY?
IN OTHER WORDS, NO DEPORTATION,
YOU CAN'T DETAIN PEOPLE OR
DEPORT PEOPLE AND YOU CAN'T
CRIMINALIZE BORDER CROSSING.
WHAT ELSE?
>> ONE OF AMERICA'S GREATEST
STRENGTHS IS RULE OF LAW.
THESE INDIVIDUALS WILL HAVE
THEIR DAY IN COURT.
ILLEGALLY, IT TELLS THEM THEY
HAVE TO LEAVE.
IT'S NOT LIKE SOMEONE IS GOING
TO PICK THEM UP.
THEY HAD THEIR DAY.
THE COURT HAS ORDERED THEM TO
LEAVE AND THEY WILL NOT LEAVE.
WE ARE GOING TO SAY THAT'S NOT
RIGHT?
PICK THEM UP, DEPORT THEM, JUST
AS THE LAW SAYS THEY SHOULD.
>> Laura: THIS IS WHAT
BILL CLINTON SAID WE SHOULD DO,
I LOVE ALL THE OLD, TERRY READ,
BARBARA JORDAN.
>> IN THE STATE OF THE UNION,
HOW MANY PEOPLE DID
PRESIDENT OBAMA DEPORT?
>> Laura: 2020 DEMOCRATS
TONIGHT, LET'S WATCH.
>> THIS IS ALL KINDS OF WRONG
AND WE ARE A BETTER COUNTRY THAN
THIS TO BE SEPARATING FAMILIES.
>> IT IS REALLY NOT ABOUT MAKING
AMERICA SAFER, BUT ABOUT
STRIKING FEAR INTO AS MANY
PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE IN ORDER TO
KEEP THIS CRISIS IN THE
HEADLINES.
>> A CRIME AGAINST HUMANITY.
>> Laura: A CRIME AGAINST
LOGICAL THOUGHT.
>> SHE WAS A PROSECUTOR, TOO.
SHE HAS A LAW DEGREE.
DOESN'T SHE BELIEVE IN THE RULE
OF LAW?
IF SHE BROKE THE LAW WHEN SHE
UPHOLD IT?
>> Laura: WHO ELSE CAN AVOID
COURT ORDERS?
>> THEY WANT TO ALLOW EVERYONE
TO COME INTO THE COUNTRY WHETHER
THEY ARE LEGAL OR NOT.
WHAT ARE WE DOING WITH THE
130,000 HOMELESS IN CALIFORNIA?
HOW MANY OF THOSE ARE VETERANS?
NOW WE ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO COME
HERE ILLEGALLY BUT NOT TAKE CARE
OF THE AMERICANS THAT THEY ARE
CUSTOMER IT IS ABSURD WHAT THEY
BELIEVE!
>> Laura: THEY HAVE COME A
LONG WAY, HAVEN'T THEY?
>> WE CANNOT ALLOW IT TO GO ON.
>> Laura: SOCIAL MEDIA SUMMIT
WENT WELL?
>> IT WAS GOOD.
YOU SHOULD BE CONCERNED ABOUT
YOUR PRIVACY AND THAT THESE
COMPANIES HAVE SO MUCH CONTROL.
90% OF EVERY SEARCH GOES THROUGH
GOOGLE.
WHAT THEY KNOW ABOUT YOU, WHAT
THEY CAN SAY ABOUT YOU AND WHAT
THEY CAN DETERMINE AND AFFECT
WHAT YOU UNDERSTAND.
>> Laura: BY THE WAY, REAL
ELECTION MEDDLING COULD BE
COMING.
>> NOT FROM RUSSIA BUT FROM
COMPANIES.